okay we'll start this second day of a
symposium say despite the nice evening
that you had your most of you are here
in the morning that's great
thank you very much and so again thank
you for joining us here I think it was
yesterday really an amazing day and it's
really a very international panel here
and that's we really appreciate all the
contributions different vision and we so
really a lot of different points but
empowering social changes the relation
between the artists and the scientists
also the mythology how we organize our
this resin seeing we see that it's what
complex huge diversity of practice a lot
of challenges at you so today what start
with a controversial topic about
innovation but to introduce this morning
a session will have Evans in pouring air
she told me and and like any event you
will give I think the keynote first I
understood well I thought was how they I
told me
so you're the composer if I understood
well and minimalistic music also working
with gamelan some redressing instrument
your so played music with Steve Hodge so
going around the world re practicing but
you're also a faculty at some MIT that
Canon assigned professor of music
holding this chair and also the faculty
director of the cast at the Center for
art science and technology so thank you
for being with us it's a great honor to
have with you and for is yours thank you
so yes this mentioned I'm Evan zip Oren
and I'm here as as faculty director of
the MIT Center for art science and
technology which I'm here with my
co-director Leela Kenny are sitting over
there and
for the panel discussion she's the
executive director we founded cast in
2012 and the topic as as you will hear
and as you know is seating innovation
and I know we're going to have a lot of
discussion about innovation over the
course of the panel discussion but
actually what's what's interesting to me
is the first word of those two words the
seeding of the and everything and the
entire practice of selecting the seeds
planting them and telling them and
bringing them to harvest which I think
can be sometimes overlooked because
innovation is so spectacular when it
occurs I want to tell you basically some
case studies from our own work and give
you a little bit of context about MIT
and maybe that will will help clarify
our perspective on all this so one of
the interesting things about being at
MIT is that there's an ethos of
innovation that surrounds everything
because you're in a place that from it's
very beginning dedicated itself to all
sorts of innovation mainly in Sciences
and engineering and so you're surrounded
by people who invented radar or or you
know are mapping the human genome or
inventing disposable razors or condensed
soup or you know many things like that
so convincing people that innovation is
important is not really a problem
convincing people that arts are
important can sometimes be a little bit
more of a challenge at a place like MIT
even though MIT has a long history with
the arts really from the beginning when
it was mainly the things you'd expect
kind of extracurricular banjo clubs and
theatrical societies and things like
that but starting in the post-war era
actually MIT became a place for artistic
innovation as well through a sequence of
events that really started in around
1967 when Georgie Kepesh Bauhaus trained
artists started the center for advanced
digital studies which really was the
first Center for artistic research in
the u.s. it's kind of where that concept
introduced the us or one of the first
places and then over the next 20 years
that were all sorts of self-contained
programs that you can see here that try
to make more of a connection between art
and science art and technology or tried
to create programs that were involved in
this and this kind of culminated maybe
in 1985 with the Media Lab technically
Media Arts and Sciences and both the
center and the Media Lab the center has
changed its name and the Media Lab is
having some fairly high-profile
difficulties right now but they're both
still ongoing ventures cast our Center
was started in 2012 and had a little bit
of a different model because what we
were coming out of was at that point the
realization and I've heard this spoken
of a lot by many of you in general and
in terms of your own home bases with a
lot of scientists and engineers who were
artistically inclined in one way or
another and a lot of artists who were
very analytical and definitely on the
ground with students which is a major
concern to us at MIT students who were
coming in able to do all sorts of things
that could code they would be writing
apps that would be playing the list B
minor Sonata they'd be improvising jazz
they wanted to act and so we were also
dealing with this educational situation
where we're trying to help these
students to figure out a life where they
didn't have to compartmentalize and
didn't have to think of leaving some
part of their being at the laboratory
door in another part at the practice
room door so the other thing about cast
when we started is that unlike all of
these ventures we or these are our
people
but we are not associated with any
particular school at MIT we're funded by
two schools and associate provost office
and private funding particularly right
now and initially from the mellon
foundation but also from private donors
and so this and we also are a virtual
Center meaning that not only are we not
housed conceptually by a school
were not housed by anybody anywhere I
mean we don't we don't have a building
we have some offices we have an amazing
staff who make all sorts of things
happen particularly on the production
side but everything else any studios any
performance spaces any classrooms any
maker spaces all these we have to for
any residences or any other programs we
do we need to partner with existing
programs and so that's been sort of a
challenge but also an opportunity
because right from the beginning what we
realized is that if we were going to do
anything of significance on the campus
or in the wider community it was going
to have to be in partnership with
existing programs so we kind of built
that into our he--this right from the
start and so since we started which was
seven and a half years ago we've worked
to a thirty-five different programs
within MIT and they're all listed here
and you can see that there they range
from things that you'd really expect
like the very arts oriented programs
that are in the School of Architecture
to hard sciences hard engineering and
even the Sloan School of Management
which is the Business School and the
size of our we because of this the size
of our programs can range from things
that are very long residency's that
could last multi years to very quick
single-shot kind of programs that kind
of come and go we the way that we do
this is we offer certain cut we offer to
support four types of activities artist
residency is cross-disciplinary classes
for credit faculty grants for artists
and designers and architects on the
effecti and also a series of public
programs which range from installations
to
a sound art series and a performing art
series and so in the seven and a half
years since we started we've brought in
more than 90 artists you can see all
this 230 class visits 17 collaborative
projects that were presented
internationally we have supported 40
courses which means we've directly
impacted 60 400 students
29 grants to creative members of the MIT
faculty and 175 public programs 67,000
attendees 24 commissioned works 18 world
premieres also two biennial symposiums
with our third coming up in April of 21
and to publications that came out of
that symposium one the book seeing
sounding sensing which Caroline Jones
edited and the other called being
material which several of us edited so
what I'd like to do really is just tell
you about a few of the resonances that
we that that we did and the ways in
which they worked and the lessons that
we learned from them and how we organize
them and how we measured outcome etc etc
so at first we can talk about Thomas
Sara Sanyo who is fairly well known in
Paris in particular I know I might speak
to a Parisian audience but I'm sure some
of you were aware of or possibly
attended the 2018 show at the Palais de
Tokyo his one-man carte blanche
exhibition and that quite wonderful
exhibition featured several works that
he had done well and done in
collaboration with MIT engineers and
scientists and artists actually over the
course of his residency which began in
2012 basically this is a matter in the
seating category of picking an artist
who you think is going to thrive in a
particular ecosystem and so because
Tomas was trained as an architect it has
a kind of fairly strong scientific
background basically our our first act
basically
day one start cast day to invite tomás
Saraceno now that was really Lila's
initiative and it was brilliant one and
we just brought him at first for an
exploratory visit we had no agenda we
had no plan we we had we just brought
him around and started introducing him
to people and seeing what conversations
ensued and then from there what kind of
projects would it soon how we could
support those make those happen and
basically quite a lot and suit and his
collaborations go on to this day with
MIT faculty in various ways but three of
the more significant ones first he very
quickly came to the attention of Marcus
wheeler who's a professor in civil
engineering and they shared a common
interest in spiders and spider webs and
so Tomas had developed this scanning
technique which you can see a little bit
but on the left a bit of the one of the
realizations of it's taking 3d tropical
spider webs and scanning them with 3ds
with lasers he had developed that
previously in 2010 at tu Darmstadt and
he showed this technique to - Marcos
Bueller Marcus Muller was very
interested and then Tomas gave the lab
is certified err a spider in residence
and the spider
they gave the spider a little home and
the spider went to work those a very
unambiguous residency clear outcome get
spider spider builds web and then and
then the the Marcus Mueller's lab kind
of refined the the scanning technique
that Tomas had developed and did their
own scanning and then built a virtual
web and Josh in who was an advanced
graduate student began doing research on
that also Isabel su and then this was
very important part of Tomas is
continuing work with the spider webs
that were shown at the Palais at the
same time Tomas Azera seen project and
this is seen at the 2015 Grand Palais
came to the interests of another
department earthen atmospheric planetary
sciences and they developed for him and
this is a an attempt as you may know to
it's kind of a collective art project to
develop fossil-free ways of moving about
the planet in the air and so eeap's
which is our than an atmospheric
planetary sciences kind of developed
this float predictor for Tomas and which
basically allows allows anybody in the
era seen project to sort of figure out
it's it's a very idealistic sort of
utopian project which actually does have
more real-world manifestations than you
might think but with the flow predictor
you can go like oh here I am in Paris
and I need an era scene way to get back
home to Boston because my flights gonna
get shut down and you can use the float
just theoretically and then you can use
the float predictor to tell you that
it's going to take you 11 it it measures
the predictive atmosphere changes and
tells you it'll take 11 days and 35
hours or whatever so there it's it's
utopian but in this case you have a
situation where with the spiders you
have coming out of just various
conversations and exchanges of ideas you
had several research papers one almost
complete dissertation and an effect on
Tomas his own art and then in the case
of of the era scene you have actually a
collective work of art that's that's
contributed to by something coming out
of the residency and then finally with
Tomas he this is the one with sound Greg
it doesn't have to it's just ambient
sound but this was a tomas actually this
is a
that's a little loud maybe
and it goes on for an hour so maybe so
Tomas asks some of us in music we had
various conversations about the
spiderweb instruments and so we
developed with using the 3d model of the
web as both a visual and a sauna fight
and a kind of tool for sonification we
created this instant immersive
installation performance piece called
spider's canvas arachnid drone which
Tomas commissioned us to do at his pal a
show so and that since been performed in
in Boston and then installed as an
installation in one of the new buildings
and MIT not permanently but it was there
for about six months so there again you
have a situation where the combination
of researchers research and art and an
artist sort of inspires actual new work
coming not from either that artist or
those researchers so it turned out to be
a very robust and kind of ongoing
collaboration they don't all work out
that multifaceted ly wonderfully but
this one did so second example this is
the work of agnya Courant polish artist
who we actually brought in because
there's a thing at MIT called the
hacking Arts Festival which which we
also helped sponsor and there was a
group of graduate students mainly in the
School of Architecture and Design who
were looking to do a wanted an artist to
give them input these were people who
worked in machine learning and machine
intelligence and also in kind of empathy
learning to read empathy and empathic
response from the internet and various
things that I frankly don't really
understand but we had the idea to bring
them together we're like Neshek grande
who's done a lot with swarm behavior and
I guess the reason I also mentioned this
is to say that one of our ways of
working which I could go into in a lot
of detail but I won't
is that our application process is very
open that I mean we have a couple
everything comes from the community and
it can come from any level of the
community from faculty to lab directors
to graduate students even undergrads
actually anybody within the MIT
community can make a proposal obviously
we have deadlines but the initial
proposal is very simple it's basically
just like a two sentence letter I'd like
to do this and maybe people have an
artist in mind maybe they have a very
specific project in mind or maybe they
have something very vague or maybe they
have something totally impossible and
then we have an iterative process
between Lila and I and our producers and
the proposer to come up with something
that fits within our mission and within
a budget and that has viability in terms
of Minnesota support which is why things
can range from you know very broad
multi-year projects to something like
this where it was just not just but I
mean where it really came from students
wanting to find somebody who could kind
of pull them all together and do a
project and we were able to accommodate
that so animal both of her works you can
actually find out more about at the
SFMOMA website open-space they're both
kind of featured there this one animal
internet she describes it essentially as
a collective Tamagotchi
and so it involves live webcams of
actual animals with these kind of
responses that are organized by
crowdsourcing empathy readings from from
the internet that's about the best I
could do with this one but because that
was such a successful project in terms
of how we gauge success which is the
engagement of the of the stakeholders
and the participants it did happen to
have a work of art that came out of it
but that's really not the measure for us
it's more just the level of
collaboration the kind of robustness of
it the kind of conversations and the
what seemed to be the offshoots
afterwards we sort of put the word out
that she was around and she caught the
interest of a researcher in csail which
is computer science
and artificial intelligence and Boris
Katz and they together worked on this
piece assembly line which is a kind of
evolving 3d sculpture based on
remunerated I want to make that clear
input from Amazon Terk workers from on
you know who can plug in self-portraits
which then she turns into into this
sculpture so it's a way of inverting
facial recognition of basically taking
that technology so in that sense I
suppose it's a slightly passive
intervention I suppose and that it's
taking it's taking an innovation that
we're all kind of terrified of and
turning it into something that that has
a different sort of use and then finally
this is what actually one of my favorite
projects and stories because you know
someone like Sarah say know is very
internationally well-known and he's
working on grand scales and he's working
with teams and he's got a factory and
and he's amazing but you know he's kind
of huge and his project took several
years Pavel Bure manchak is another
Polish artist he's a sound artist and he
runs a collective called male instrument
II in Rostov and basically we brought
him in because there's this fantastic
maker culture at MIT that's kind of you
know now is blessed with that name but
basically it was kind of circuit benders
and and tinkerers and a lot of that at a
place like MIT tends to happen under the
radar because people are doing things
like you know huge you know multi-year
experiments or
working collectively to create pictures
of black holes but there's also just a
lot of people who want to like take a
drill and some PVC pipe and some
electronics and make stuff and Pavel
does this in this incredibly creative
and kind of went whimsical way that's
also quite profound so essentially we
invite
Pawel to come and just sit in a room
with about a dozen students and a bunch
of piles of junk that they bought at the
Home Depot and that actually from MIT
recycling areas which turned out to be
very important and they simply spent a
week making instruments and then
composing music for it and doing a
concert so that's all great that was a
really that was a very nice thing the
guy on the left in this picture was a
undergraduate named Peter kadar and
Peter at that time was a mechanical
engineering undergrad and kind of
part-time jazz pianist and then Peter
left MIT this was during his senior year
I think it was 2015 he graduated went
into private industry came back two
years later to do a graduate degree and
to keep playing in the MIT Jazz Band and
in that jazz band we had sponsored a
commission by a composer named Miguel
Zenon who's a Puerto Rican activist
musician and the group had gone down to
Puerto Rico and in the course of the
outreach that we had sort of built into
the to the program the group met climate
activists who were working on
desalinization and you know just the
water crisis and the in the wake of
Hurricane Maria and so then Peter came
back and he did two things and one of
them was that he became director of the
Jazz Band and began writing pieces on
climate control themes which is you know
obviously really nice and has some
impact but also change the whole nature
of his research so that now what he's
doing is it's just beginning stage
research and it's simply one graduate
student but instead of looking for ways
to go into the private sector to kind of
make profit generating devices he's now
working with actually that the it's a
slight it's related to the urinator on a
certain way and that he's using recycled
materials to actually generate energy
to go toward desalinization projects and
you can read about that at
sustainability mit.edu so that's a very
simple and straightforward outcome that
when we talk about measuring success and
whether it comes in a completed artwork
sometimes you get that in the case of
the Saracino or an art nasha Courant and
when it comes into you know some kind of
measure that's going to please engineers
or scientists like like published
research papers dissertations new
technologies etc sometimes you get that
but for me I I think that what makes me
most personally proud is just this kind
of on the ground here is one person who
was trying to put together their
interest in art and technology in a in a
meaningful way and through these
resonances not directly but just through
the combination of them and through it
through an atmosphere in which both are
valued and both are seen as having
something to do with each other
something new comes out of it so where
that goes for him or for anybody else
any of the other 6,400 students that
we've been able to reach so far that
remains to be seen but that is what
we're trying to do thank you
and then thank you very much for sharing
where this is quite impressive
I've seen the installation of SAS and I
think they also have this sound of the
spider remember and the installation in
Milan you can even hear the sound of
this he does several projects with that
and and I was lucky enough to get
involved with those he had this thing
called the the spider jam sessions where
he could and yeah you he'd mic the
spiders and I know that this can also
work with him in a collaboration so
there's a good Network and so I will
also call out my distinguished other